ellen degeneres had david letterman on
her daytime talk show one last time
before her 19th season run comes to an
end on may 26th and from one legendary
talk show host to other uh david shared
how he felt when he his show came to an
end while giving ellen some advice on
how to move forward thanks for joining
us everybody take care bye-bye
i felt great about the show until all of
the set was in a dumpster out on 53rd
street and then it was suddenly oh yeah
it's show business bang zoom thanks good
night did you take anything from the set
nope nope took nothing i'm not one of
those memory lane guys yeah uh but i i
have some advice for you and i've
learned this
uh i'm not just some guy
i well i am but i learned this when the
show's over i'm not kidding take some
time off take a week ten days like that
travel
visit family visit friends and then
immediately get another show
okay because it just doesn't work okay
so everything in 10 days just just
travel and rest in 10 days
if you're that kind of person fine i
wouldn't go two weeks two weeks would be
dangerous okay
a week 10 days okay you're right back at
it and get another job
yeah okay
all right you'll thank me for that yeah
okay i i do plan on you know doing
something by the way am i supposed to
there's a gift there is that for me oh
oh i'm sorry no i'm going to a party
later